all right
ready to start
so um
welcome
um
yeah
my name is Odin
I come from the consultancy Cuda Market
and my fascination with crypto started
some years ago
um
I bought some ethereum for 10 dollars
and I was really happy when I sold it at
20.
100 return on investments
some time later uh it's yeah the the
value was almost five thousand dollars
well hey it's not like I'm bitter or
anything so uh
today I'm going to talk about a pyramid
of dumpster fires uh that is a like web3
is a controversial subject
and it involves crypto and blockchain
technology and that's an area that's
full of scams pyramid schemes and and
hype but but I will not deal with that
today let's just put that aside and what
we'll do instead is to just look at the
technology itself and to see how it
really works and from a developer's
perspective and we will try to figure
out if it's as good as people say it is
um
my goal with this presentation is that
when you leave today you will know more
about what a smart contract is
and I think this is important in this
day and age because it enables you to
form your own opinion and to ask
critical questions about a technology
that promises a lot
and especially when you add like large
economical value into the mix it's
really easy to to lose your head and
just not think clearly so first I'm
going to Define web 3 then I'm going to
take a closer look at blockchains
and then we're going to get to Smart
contracts I'm going to show you a couple
of examples one of which I made myself
which is Tamagotchi that lives on the
blockchain
sounds really weird but I will show you
and lastly we will look at how to
actually develop smart contracts
but first let's define web 3. there is
no clear definition that everyone can
agree on here but here is at least one
way to explain it
begins with web one and that is the open
internet of the 90s where you have like
open decentralized protocols and the
users they typically consume content
from static web servers
and then we have web 2 which is the
internet of the 2000s with the huge uh
centralized platforms like Facebook and
Google and
um
where the users typically produce the
content for this platforms so they can
make money
web3 is going to be like a solution to
this where we're going to go back to the
open decentralized protocols and the
users are going to take back control
they're now enabled to own their own
stuff and also participate in the
governance of the thing
um and this is going to be done with
blockchain technology all right but what
is a blockchain really
I will only give like a high level
description here it's really easy to get
lost in the details and there's a lot of
interesting technical uh stuff to to
really dig into here but there's also a
lot of terminology and buzzwords but I
will only cover enough to like get an
understanding of the basics of this
technology to better understand its
constraints and that is important
so
what is it well at its core it's just a
database you can write and you can read
data from it
but importantly it's a decentralized
database so there is this network like a
peer-to-peer network of computers and
every node has its own copy of the
database
and then there is some kind of rule or
algorithm that enables you to write to
the database
um and a critical aspect here is that
it's an open system everyone who wants
to can participate so you don't need to
be given access by like a centralized
party to to play along
it's a really slow database as well so
Bitcoin can do about seven transactions
per second and ethereum which I'm going
to cover in detail here can do about 15.
but there's something more important to
consider and that is the confirmation
time
so in ethereum it takes five minutes
before your transaction is confirmed
what does that mean that means that you
will have to wait five minutes in order
for you to know that your transaction
has been accepted by the system and
written to the database
just think about that five minutes
it's an expensive database as well so
depending on the amount of traffic on
the network and
like what you actually want to achieve
you'll have to pay somewhere between one
and twenty dollars minimum
to do one transaction
but how can we get the nodes in the
network to agree about the state of the
database well this is where the
consensus algorithm comes in and and we
have to consider malicious actors here
as well there might be someone that
tries to to steal your or like subvert
the system somehow
so how can we reach consensus in a
distributed system
we have the classical algorithms but
those have a couple of constraints that
are not good for us in in this kind of
crypto blockchain world and that is that
every node has to know each every other
node and
um also uh every node has to talk to
every other node so this only scales so
far
so we can't use that
um there this is where proof of work
comes along so this is like the original
crypto consensus mechanism that was
introduced with Bitcoin
I'll try to explain that now
um
how does that work
well here we have Alice she is sitting
on her computer she's not connected to
the internet anything and she wants to
create a wallet the only thing she has
to do is to generate a public key key
pair
um and she just needs to keep her
private part uh Secrets right and then
by using that key pair she can derive an
address and with that address anyone
else in the system can send her value
and when she's ready she can also
transfer value to the system and she
does this by signing a transaction with
her private key and only she can do that
all right
but what happens with the transaction
then once you've sent it into the
network
well
first we need to see what the data
structure is and that is a ledger that's
just a long list of transactions and
it's append only you can't delete
transaction from it
and
here we have a network of notes or
miners in proof of work so
um
the users they send in their unconfirmed
transactions into this network of
Miners and it doesn't matter which Miner
they they talk to these unconfirmed
transactions they are like shared
between the miners and they go into
what's called a memory pool think of it
like a waiting room for unconfirmed
transactions
but how do these transactions get out of
the battery enrollment into the database
let's take a closer look at one of the
miners so this Miner he has a memory
pool
and um
then he needs to figure out how to make
a block and a block that that has a
certain amount of space so it's not not
certain that it can fit all the
transactions from the memory pool into
the block
so how does he decide which that which
transactions go into the block well when
you make a transaction you can add a
little fee or that that's like a little
tip to the miner
and by using that the miners just picks
out the biggest tips
and then he gives himself a little
reward for doing this
um so remember this block hasn't been
confirmed yet so this is just the
starting point
so what happens with this block well the
miner using the the
algorithm of the proof of work system
here
uh he's he then starts uh what's called
like a guessing game
this is where all the miners try to
compete with each other
so how does that work well we take the
block and we put it into a hash function
and this is a cryptographic hash
function and and that means that it's a
one-way function
so you can't go from the result and back
to the input easily
what does that look like well it's just
some random numbers and the name of the
game here is for the miner to try to
figure out a hash that starts with a
certain number of zeros up front
and and like the goal of the system at
least in Bitcoin is to do a block every
10 minutes and whenever blocks are found
too fast they just increase the
difficulty and that is just adding more
zeros to the requirement of the block
um so but how does he find this number
well this is where the work part of
proof of work comes in so the miner just
has to insert a number as well into the
hash function
and there's no way other than just
trying lots of different numbers here
and this is where the miner has to spend
a lot of CPU
um so the nice thing is that it's really
hard to find this hash but once you've
found it it's really cheap for every
other Miner to verify that yes this
Miner actually found the secret number
and that's that's the key here and also
we tuck on the previous hash of the
previous block
and this is the Block Chain this is
where that concept comes in but why do
we do that
well let's have a closer look at that
here we have uh just a list of blocks
and let's say someone wants to delete
the transaction that Dave did to Alice
how would that work well
by removing that transaction the hash of
that block will change so then the miner
would have to try to figure out that
number but also it would also have to
figure out the numbers for all the other
blocks that point to it so this is where
the confirmation time that I talked
about earlier comes in right you have to
wait an hour and the reason for that in
Bitcoin is that you typically have to
wait for six confirmation in order to be
like sure that your block with your
transaction is like piled on top of with
as much CPU power as possible Right
so
there's one last crucial piece to
explain proof of work and that is that
the state of the database at any one
point in time is governed by the longest
chain that exists
that represents the the chain that has
the most work invested in it
okay so let's say we have a list of
transactions here and in the last one
someone has bought a Lambo and it's been
delivered and then we have the The Miner
who has the lambo he wants to
um like double spend his money he wants
this transaction to never have happened
so what it does then
here we have an evil Miner he then only
the only thing he has to do is just to
create the longest chain right he just
have to figure out the numbers the
fastest and the reason this doesn't work
is that
um
the amount of hashing power that all the
good miners has
has to be like more than what the evil
Miner has
right so in order to attack this system
you would have to acquire
um lots of hashing power
okay
so proof of work solves a really hard
problem and that is how to achieve
distributed consensus and and it does it
in a really smart way in like a
technical interesting way so
um
the problem here is of course is that
the cost is really high when it comes to
energy use so so it's not a sustainable
solution and everyone agrees about that
so we need an alternative
and one alternative is proof of stake so
actually ethereum they just switched
over from proof of work to proof of
stake a couple of weeks ago then the
world's energy consumption it fell by
0.02 percent which is like insane
amounts of energy
so
um how does proof work a proof of stake
actually work well there's no need to
guess
a random number anymore
so what what what's done instead is that
in order to participate as a node in
this system to be able to write
transactions to the database they're
they're called validators or stakers
then you just have to
put aside a certain amount of stake or
tokens so those represent an economical
value right and by doing so you have to
lock them down right and by doing so you
are done and enabled to participate as a
Staker
okay
so here we have validators in a network
and all of them have locked down a
certain amount of stack and the more
stake you lock down the more often you
get to write to the database and get a
reward
and then there's some kind of algorithm
that decides at given intervals who will
get to write the next block so here we
have one of the validators he has been
allowed to read from the memory pool
create a new transaction block and give
themselves a little reward and then he
updates his database and then he ships
the new block to all the other
validators and I update their database
so the security here lies in the fact
that in order to subvert the system you
would have to buy a lot of stick and
that is really expensive
so
we've solved the problem of energy use
but to get what we have gotten another
problem and that is that proof of stake
by definition means that the rich are
now in control
just as with the centralized platforms
with the riches are in control
okay
um that is a different discussion I
won't get into that here but uh just
think about that
so
let's have a look at smart contracts
the name is really misleading because
the contracts they are not smart and
it's not a contract in the legal sense
of the world
so it's just code that can be run on a
blockchain
it can write and read to the distributed
database
and it's kind of like a stored procedure
but not quite
so
how to explain that this is just a
regular transaction this is just a
transfer value from one address to
another
um a smart contract invocation looks
like this it is also a transfer of value
from one address to the address of the
smart contract so you can actually send
money to a Smart contract and then you
can tack on some data and this
represents a function call so this is a
function call to do stuff to that smart
contract and you add some parameters to
it
and that's it really it's it's not more
complex than that but now we have of
course you have a virtual machine that
can read this kinds of transaction and
actually execute the code and update the
database
here's my attempt to explain
what a smart contract looks like so it
has an ID a unique ID it's just a hash
and once you've deployed it it can never
change the code is immutable you can
change it
it has a set of variables that you can
read and write to
and it has a set of methods
in this case these are read methods and
those are free to invoke everyone can
invoke them as much as they like it
doesn't cost you anything
however if you want to write to the
execute the right function that cost
token and the price depends on how much
data you're going to write how much CPU
you're going to spend what the developer
charges for that invocation and also how
much traffic there is on the network
but
um
there's also a wallet so that smart
contract can actually store tokens
I will show you an example of that
so
it's basically programmable value that's
that's the idea
okay so the smart contracts themselves
they live inside the distributed
database
what does that mean well that means that
when you as a developer deploy your
smart contracts
the code is compiled to bytecode and
it's shipped into the decentralized
network and to deploy that costs you
tokens because your code takes space and
the more code you write the more
expensive it is to deploy and you have
to pay every time you deploy
everyone in the world can call the
functions in your contracts
it's totally open
this includes of course malicious actors
it might be that someone wants to
actually steal the value that's inside
your wallet inside your smart contracts
wallet
so making smart contracts makes requires
a very very high level of attention to
security
and there's lots of examples of hacks
like millions of dollars lost there
the code itself usually does the serious
programmers or developers here they
choose to actually publish their source
code
um but that means that the malicious
actors actually can read your code as
well as invoke all your functions and
that gives them a level of access
compared to traditional system which is
just
unheard of right so there's no firewall
here there's no monitoring there's no
nothing right you're totally in the open
so why would people choose to publish
their source code well your regular
users also need to read your code in
order to understand what your contract
is going to do to their value to the
money right
so
smart contracts they run in a really
constrained environments this isn't like
a regular programming environment
what do I mean by that well
a smart contract can only access its own
state
it can also invoke other smart contracts
but it has to be invoked from the
outside either by a user with a wallet
or just a system with a wallet
you can't invoke yourself as a smart
contract that means you can't like have
like a periodic job that that does uh
stuff to your smart contract
um or you can't like listen to events or
stuff like that that has to be invoked
from the outside from centralized
systems
and you can't call out to external web
servers
you can't fetch data from the outside or
you can't even like write data to the
outside
you can though like emit events that
external systems can listen to
so if you take a step back that means
that um
are smart contracts invocation that is
like a pure function it takes the state
of the system and a transaction and it
produces the next state of the system
and this has consequences
it means that you cannot have Randomness
in smart contracts
it has to be deterministic
why is this
here we have a validator node it has a
new block to write
right it's been elected to to write the
next block and this block contains just
transactions and some of which are smart
contract implications so what does the
miner has to do to update his sorry the
Staker has to do in order to update his
database well it takes the standard
database and the list of transaction
into the
um
virtual machine function right and it
emits the next state
and then he ships that new block to all
the other validators
and the thing now is that they what do
they have to do well they have to to
execute exactly the same code as the
first validator and they have to do this
in order to verify that that's correct
and to update their database
right this is why it has to be
deterministic if it was any Randomness
in here you wouldn't get the same result
across the entire network and that would
be a problem
so interestingly if you take a step back
that means that a smart contract
invocations represents a single thread
of computation across thousands of
machines so ironically compared to
traditional systems where you can scale
by adding machines horizontally you
can't do that there's no parallelism
here
this is why blockchains are slow
well they are actually trying to figure
this out and try to like scale this uh
the system and there's like lots of
different approaches here like side
chains level two level three sharding
none of which are in widespread use and
common to all of them is that they
complicate an already complex system
there's a lot of security pitfalls here
and it also increases the attack surface
of the entire blockchain system
so
by scaling they typically also impose
restrictions on the system as a whole
that affect the usability of the thing
but hey who knows maybe they will figure
this out in the future
um and as a side note I know there are
blockchains that I've claimed to solve
this but they are not widely used and
thus you can't be sure that they
actually work at scale
okay let's have a look at the Oracle
problem so this is an oracle the
software company then you have a
different kind of problem
um this is um
it turns out that actually getting data
reading data from the outside world in a
smart contract is really useful and
there are lots of examples of that
actually
so it might be that you want to like
make a decentralized stock exchange and
then you need to have price data from
the outside and let's say you want to
make an insurance contract where you pay
Farmers money when there's a flood and
then you need weather data and let's say
you want to have a will in as a smart
contract then you need to know if people
have died or not and also just
Randomness like getting that into the
system is really useful
and this is called the Oracle problem
and the Oracle here of course is like
the the service that is the interface
between the smart contract and the
external world
um so it turns out that you actually can
do it by doing just this like you just
you have an external service that's just
a regular web server on the internet and
that just pays to put data into the
system at regular intervals right write
some Randomness in every 10 minutes or
something
there's actually also a way to read data
on demand so how does that work well
here we have a smart contract that you
have made and we have an Oracle and it
has some kind of data that you want
that's just the regular server on the
internet
the Oracle has its own smart contract
that it monitors
for changes
so when you want to fetch data you have
to initiate a transaction from the
outside and you say I want Foo and you
have to pay for that right and then your
smart contract talks to the Oracle smart
contract and writes into its state hey
this smart contract wants food
right and the Oracle sees that
and it writes full right
and of course we can just skip all that
and just pay the Oracle directly right
to do the same thing
um yeah we'll solved the problem haven't
we well
except you have taken a decentralized
system now and leaned it on a
centralized service in order to do
something useful
you have to trust the Oracle and that's
just a server on the internet it can go
down it can fake data but most
importantly you have to trust a
centralized service
so you have to wonder why use the smart
contract at all in this case
okay how does Smart contracts work as
seen from a user I'll try to explain
that here so here we have
um it's just um
a regular person with a laptop it might
also just be a smartphone right and he
goes to xyz.com that's just a regular
web server and it has some HTML HTML on
it and some JavaScript and inside is
browser he has a wallet as well I'll get
to that and I'll show an example of that
later
and then the
page is loaded in its browser and in
during the initialization there is some
JavaScript library typically that will
talk to the external system and the
smart contracts right like this and it
will read the state of the smart
contracts and then you can draw it in
your browser
doesn't cost anything it's free everyone
can do this
but let's say you want to update some
data
how would that work well let's say you
click a button inside this page
then your wallet is going to pop up and
say hey this is this interaction is
going to cost you so and so much and
then you sign it
and then you send your transaction to
the decentralized system
and then you wait five minutes
yeah
okay
but I've lied to you
what is really happening here
there are some details here that are
crucial to understand
you just you can't just trust the random
computer on the internet your browser
can't just talk to one of the nodes in
the decentralized system it might be
malicious
right
so ideally you would have to run your
own personal note on a server that you
control and that server would run the
blockchain software and it will like
sync the distributed database and then
your browser will have to be configured
to talk to that personal note but if
there's one thing we'll learn the last
30 years it is that no one wants to run
their own server
so
because you have to run it somewhere
right you have to patch security updates
you have to keep it online you have to
have enough disk space you have to pay
for power so not even developers these
days want to run their own server right
so it's just too much hassle so
virtually no one runs their own note
what do they do instead
well
they use the centralized service
everyone does this so there's a couple
of companies that's really huge in this
space and basically everyone uses this
even the wallets do this
when I discovered this this was like a
huge surprise to me I couldn't believe
it like so much technology and effort
to make a decentralized trustless system
and then we just throw it out the window
and rely on a few companies without any
verification
this smells like a lot like a web 2
system
yeah and of course this centralized
service it can see all your read
transactions so it's similar to like
surfing the web through a third-party
server that can see all your web traffic
um
yeah and why do we do this well the API
is faster it's better it has access to
history and analytics yeah
my point here is that the dream of
decentralization just isn't true
okay but let's look at something fun
this is an example of a smart contract
it's a non-fungible token you probably
heard about those
um
here we have a smart contract that is an
nft
um
this is a picture it's a movie and it's
also like a physical box that shows the
movie it's pretty cool actually
and this was sold for 29 million dollars
okay let's have a look at the technology
behind that
we can see that there's a smart contract
address here and that is the that
represents the Ft it can hold a lot of
tokens like different images and stuff
and we can see that the token IDE in
this case is one so just remember
remember that we need that later
how can we actually have a look at this
smart contract well there's this thing
called block explorers on the internet
and that's just a service that runs a
node and it also has some kind of web
service and database and stuff to enable
you to search for uh transactions that
have happened you can find Smart
contracts
um so let's just use one of those
we put the address of the smart contract
into that and we find
the source code
and you can read that if you want
it also has functionality where we can
actually interact with this contract we
can like execute read and write
transactions here it's it's kind of like
Swagger or open API if you use that
so let's try to find the images
so uh we invoke a function a read
function that's called token URI and
that gets back a URL to just a regular
web server
where's the image
well it turns out that to with today's
prices to store one kilobyte of data
costs about 200 000 kroner
to store the image and the movie
would cost you seven and a half million
and that's shy of a million dollars so
that's insane that nobody does that so
yeah let's just point to a web server
instead
let's have a look at that
URL
here we can find metadata about the nft
this can be anything really but in this
case it follows a certain standard that
all the nft sites can use to like list
all the nfts that's in a smart contracts
and you can use this to like show an
avatar on your social media page
whatever
the interesting part here is that we can
find the image reference here we can
find the image and the movie reference
and that is also just a link to a web
server
okay so what do you actually own when
you buy an nft with this smart contract
do you own the image
let's break that down
the picture file is stored in a web
server just a regular web server
the metadata think of it as the sign
that points to the image that is also
just stored on a web server
like obviously here the the image can
disappear the servers can go down
someone can like take over the domain so
this is not a good good Solution by any
stretch of the imagination and everyone
agrees on that
but what you actually own so the URL is
stored in the distributed Ledger
so what you own is the sine to the sign
to the picture that's what you own
I'm not sure but I'm not convinced that
this actually is worth 29 million
dollars
yeah but it's even worse than that
because if you read the contract you
will find a function that's called set
token URI okay it's it's protected by
admin required but that just means that
the guy that made this contract can do
this
so
even the URL can change
yeah
but it's even even worse than that
because blockchains can Fork what does
that mean well that's exactly what
happened uh to ethereum couple of weeks
ago and now we have two chains one that
uses proof of stake and then we have one
that uses proof of work
so now your nft is in two databases
yeah what happens when you sell them in
one of them right
so my point here is that there is trust
involved here and that is trust between
humans
technology can only get you so far
ah but uh there are probably some
critics along you here now that will say
but aha there's a fix for this problem
we can avoid using regular web servers
and we can do that with a technology
called distributed file systems
um there's a couple of examples of this
it's also called content adjustable
storage that there's like ipfs and R
weave so how does that work well
you take the picture file and you hash
it and you store the picture file inside
the distributed file system and the hash
is a unique key that represents that
picture
so you can fetch that picture using hash
and then you take that hash and put it
into the metadata
and then you have to metadata and then
you put the metadata into
the blockchain okay problem solved right
well it's an interesting technology and
I would say it's pretty early at this
stage
but what is
certain is that someone has to pay to
store the files
so either you have to participate by
running a node in the distributed file
system
or have you have to pay someone to do it
there's lots of examples of like really
expensive nfts that just gone missing
from ipfs
so my point here is that if you ever buy
an nft
you really need to look into the details
you need to read the contracts you need
to figure out where stuff is stored and
you might even have to help out in
storing the file so basically there's a
risk that your nft can just go missing
okay
let's have a closer look at how to
develop smart contracts so
what would an ideal language look like
for developing smart contracts as we
have seen it is a pretty constrained
development environment right so we need
something that really fits here
so let's take a closer look uh it should
be the language should be secure which
is that it should be easy to make code
that's hard to exploit for malicious
actors because a bug can be costly for
you and also your users
it should be simple
so it's easy to understand the code
right so your user needs to understand
your code to understand what your smart
contract is going to do to their money
this is a perfect job for declarative or
functional kinds of languages right and
I say this because they control side
effects and mutations and in general
they lend themselves to be verified or
proved
um
and then we have the imperative kinds of
languages think of like Java or c-sharp
or JavaScript
and they uh they they yeah
they have no control over side effects
they do rampant mutation and in general
um hard to reason about and they have
lots of pitfalls when it comes to
security
which can cost you dearly
but you can take a little guess about
what's the most popular in the
blockchain world
yeah
and the reason for that is pretty easy
to understand it's just that that's what
people know and that's what they want to
use
that's just how the world is
so the most popular language is called
solidity and that sounds solid enough
right
um
it's made by the ethereum foundation and
that those
sit on about a billion dollars in our
bank accounts and they can also lean on
70 years of programming language
research so that should lead to the
perfect language right
well let's have a look at their
documentation
it is heavily influenced by C plus
and I like C plus as much as the next
guy but
um
this is not a fitting choice I would say
the version of the language is 0.816 so
okay this is this is an experiment and
it's not final yet but
I'm not sure of all the users actually
understand this
um
but it gets worse than that because
let's have a look at the changelog from
the latest version
it contains a lot of breaking changes
and as a programmer this sends shivers
down my spine right they don't care
about backwards compatibility
whatever
other weird stuff is they don't have
support for floats okay but sometimes
you need to divide two numbers and know
what the result is
and also they have Maps or hash Maps
but there's no way to list the keys this
room of when I saw this the first time
in like why why
um let's have a look at that so here we
have an example this is a mapping or a
hash map between an address and
a number we can use this to make a high
score if you make if you make a game
but the problem is that we can't list
the keys so we can't make a high score
unless you yourself have an array next
to it
so you yourself as a programmer need to
keep the keys
so whenever you update the hashmap you
need to remember to take care of the key
as well then you can use this array to
iterate of the keys and like kick out
the values from the hashmap
yeah this is just one of the many things
that is off by this language here so
it's it's obviously under active
development right that's fine
um they opted for a strategy for going
fast and breaking things and that's a
smart strategy for getting mindshare
because after all they are the most
popular language
what I as a developer would not feel
confident in programming in solidity
it's just too hard
okay it's time for the demo
this is an example of what you can
actually do with smart contracts so like
I said it's a Tamagotchi but before I
show you that
I will show you the architecture of the
thing
it's what's called a DOT or a
decentralized application and that's
just a regular web page here and it has
a UI with HTML and JavaScript and I have
a library called web3js and that is what
I use to talk to the smart contract in
the decentralized system
so this is what I'm going to show you
the demo this is it
but usually in in other kinds of dapps
you can add a backend to the mix
which is just a regular web server with
the database
and usually also you have a web3 library
that can talk to the smart contract and
like monitor it and do stuff when
data changes
so my point here is that
typical daps they are usually a mix and
it's not it's usually just like the core
logic and the core State that's stored
in the contract
all right so let's have a look at the
demo
uh two seconds
thank you
all right
okay so I made this thing with the react
and 3js and yeah I might have over
engineered this demo a little bit uh but
uh yeah
currently it's it's dead right the
Tamagotchi is that so let's try to
revive it
I'll click this button here
and
you can see that my wallet pops up
and then I can see that oh yeah this
costs 0.01 tokens and I press confirm
oh yeah I need my password of course
you don't need to see that
let's see
okay and now we don't have to wait five
minutes this is just a test test net so
usually this will go much slower
okay
so let's see
is this the demo effect oh yeah no he's
alive he's ready to to play okay so uh
now what will happen is that time will
pass and his power will go down and his
mood will go down and in about 10
minutes if no one interacts with him
he'll die again
which is kind of sad
um but if you can look down here you
will see a button that says withdraw
right and
only I can see that because my address
is my wallet's address is hard coded
here so only I will see that as a
developer right so only I can withdraw
the tokens here right
um
and
you can try to actually invoke the
withdrawal function in the smart
contract but that won't work because
also my address is hard coded into that
function so it's protected
hopefully
um and let's try to interact again so
I'll press the power button here let's
try to charge them up
you can see that it costs 0.01 and I do
that again and this number down here
should increase to zero point
12. that is the amount of value that's
inside the smart contracts wallets
yeah now it's charging and yeah exactly
so this is just to show one way that you
can earn money on this
right okay so that is it for the demo
yeah let's see
so in the end now I just want to revisit
something I said in the beginning and
that is that smart contracts are
immutable and it turns out that's not
entirely true
the code itself is mutable you can't
change the code
but what do I mean well let's say you
have a smart contract like this
and then you discover a bug or there's a
security issue with the platform or you
just want to add a new feature right so
as developers we know that code is a
living thing and there will always be
reasons to update the code
but how would that work well
um we can create a new version of our
code and push that out and that will
create a new smart contract and then we
have to tell all our users to use the
new address so in my case with the with
the Tamagotchi that's not a problem
because the address to the contract is
embedded inside the JavaScript so I'll
just have to update my web server and
then everything will be fine but there
there might be other cases where this is
more cumbersome where you have to update
all of your clients somehow
okay so right
um one thing that we have forgotten now
is that uh
your users might have interacted with
the previous version and actually paid a
lot of money to put State into that
contract so you as a developer then
would have to copy that state and that
can cost you millions of dollars
so that's not ideal
okay
um
there is a solution here which everyone
uses and that is the following
you have a proxy contract
and that's the interface that all your
users are using
and the proxy contract sits on the state
so in case you want to add more kinds of
variables or state in the future you
would have to accommodate for that when
you create this contract like make extra
variables which sounds weird but that's
what they do and then the logic of the
contract would be in a separate contract
so when you update you do the following
you just push out a new version and you
have a new smart contract and you just
update the reference stored in the proxy
contract because that's just a variable
you can change that
problem solved right well
let's say this contract is a
decentralized Exchange
that sits on millions of dollars of
value
and at any point in time using this
pattern the developers can do the
following they can add a steel method
and just empty out all the value and
just
go away
this happens all the time
right and it's even called a rug pull
right so
it's it's horrible
so once again my point here is that you
have to trust people even Developers
so technology cannot replace trust
between humans
okay so web3 to me is a really a
fascinating subject because the the
distance between the hype and the actual
technology is so large
we have now seen that it's not as
decentralized as you'd think
the development environment has a lot of
room for improvements it's slow it's
expensive you have to trust the
developers you have to trust centralized
servers and and also something I haven't
talked about at all is there's tax
implications here as well so just look
forward to the day when one of your kids
say Hey Dad I need some help running my
taxes because I've played web3 Minecraft
uh yeah
is this technology the future
the true believers they say yes all the
problems will be solved eventually this
is just technology and Technology
improves
well they're not solved at this point in
time so in my opinion we're still at the
demo stage of this technology
and it's like a solution looking for a
problem to solve and that's a decade
after its Inception but hey who knows
maybe they'll figure this out in the
future
okay so I hope after this presentation
that you're now better able to ask
questions
when people pitch
blockchain-based solutions to you
if you have any questions you can just
come up to me afterwards and we can have
a chat
thanks
[Applause]